citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to leave our reality and go to another
reality with Batman Gotham by Gaslight
you excited John I am so excited I've
heard I've Just Seen The Vibes of this
and I feel like it'd be right up my Alle
I'm uh I've never seen it I know the
comic and the comic is old enough that I
don't know how much they'll follow this
little elor thing it's Mike mola if I
remember correctly but I'm very excited
for an elor you lovelies know the drill
let us know in the comments what you
want us to watch next do you want us to
go back to the tomorrow verse do you
want us to watch more elor do you want
us to go watch Young Justice what do you
want let us know that's why I pluged it
know that we've been reading it because
I see that a lot so let us know in the
comments below what you want next uh if
by now you've noticed we started a
certain other animated show click on
over to there as well because I want you
people to know we're watching the
current stuff as well so reject Nation
dive on in hit that notification Bell
hit that like button hit that comment
hit all the YouTube things and as ever
thank you to the fine folks at prepper
who make this all very possible they
prep we deliver and then they deliver
and it's all prep thanks to prepper
thank you if you want to watch any of
these in their entirety including the
entirety of the my adventures with
Superman full length watch alongs head
on over to patreon where you can watch
it beginning to end and enjoy the
Artistry the Majesty the ustc of our
resting face
so over there at patreon and become a
super sexy reject without further Ado
let's dive into the Gaslamp district
it's Comic-Con baby Gotham by gasl let's
go now will we get a horse and buggy in
the opening
shop is I bet all of my tuppin on that
or whatever the TPP we're going to be
still in America right if that's a word
Oh I thought I got I saw a little oh
there is a horse and buy there is
perfect very proud of that silly thing
that just happened may change but things
stay the
same in a train we're getting all the
modes of Transport guys what are the
chances like this is literally do they
do this on purpose cuz that is they do
they know they know they have booster
Golds time machine they've watched these
and they're like those guys love yeah
just for John Andy the Gotham gay girls
presents iy the plant lady the gayy
girls the plant
[Music]
lady kids this movie is rated R we don't
know what might happen to those leaves
ask your parents about burlesque and V
various other live art forms we just
don't know if fall is coming will Autumn
cause these leaves to fall it's r at R
we'll see let's see those leaves this
man is demanding all them it's not what
burles is about by the way it's not it's
true is that one in that East Hollywood
that perlesque bar it's awesome jumbo
jumbo clown shout out to Jumbo's Clown
Room beautiful place now which DC
character would hang out there Lobo Lobo
yep and I'm sure the Joker rolls through
once in a while just because he's
obligated oh actually I wonder if he's
the villain of this detective Jack the
Ripper we never discovered him that'd be
cool oh my God Jack Napier
hey oh wait it might you gave me a start
I thought for a minute be lonely
I hate to see a man lonely uh-oh I got a
generous nature and I'm sure you're
generous too a you
mister going all in on this dialogue or
maybe you don't want to
wait right here in the alleyway
baby
no you took the shortcut through outside
his territory got to pay the Tariff
ain't that right Dicky names Jason
remember
they're all Robins it's getting awful
late don't go yell on me boy you know
what you get everyone is Ray Winstone
but is it Ray Winstone nope I've been
down the RO too many times Coy we've
been misled before never Ray
Winstone now pay up the first Tim Drake
really in elor I think we might have
broke him boys the
B ain't just a story young one oh I like
the cloak
holy
boys
really I wouldn't work for that guy
anymore no no real poor judge of
[Music]
action Vengeance now you're in big Bill
dust territory interfering with my
amiable Robins you're bad for
business bad all round iconic villain
build dust yeah got old Billy dust love
him oh oh dude this is our family now
making something here taking something
back from Gotham make something
else we got no choice you'll just chase
us down find us
again oh go to St kadala ask for sister
Leslie she'll help you she'll hook it up
would be nice to actually get a Tim
Drake right like we did briefly I guess
oh oh
no what a
shot so has Ivy withered they just
merked Ivy right off the bat
Stakes I wonder if we'll get Harley
because the Harley Quinn definitely fits
the setting sure oh my
God are there supposed to be from Hell
Vibes oh there definitely are okay
definitely Alan Moore influence is here
and tears that's what turned this dream
into a magnificent reality that and
Bruce Wayne's money Capital Money Money
Money this special preview of the Gotham
World's Fair
sweet meet me in Old Gotham Gotham how
much money does Bruce have yeah this day
built a town I refer you to medical
expert and Gotham's premier alienist Dr
Hugo Strange yes ride the wheel and I
give you my guarantee as a physician and
surgeon you will live how'd you make
that sound so creepy women are being
gutted in the streets like wild game and
the Gotham police stand twiddling their
thumbs some Gin soaked women of the
street have met their fate as is common
to their kind as they deserve wow bro
those mut chops women alike will be safe
from Jack Jack the Ripper yes that's
what he calls himself in the letter he
sent the Gotham Gazette sister Leslie
that Letter's likely just another hoax
Oh Sister Leslie I heard about this
little city council meeting and thought
it was a good opportunity to see how my
money was being spent and all I see is
sour
faces I like the mutton chop idea on his
face yeah I've seen the bodies Bruce cut
to pieces like an autopsy strange the
top man at Arkham tells us he's never
seen this kind of controlled savagery
before what about Jonathan Crane That
Could also be a jack ooh that's true
latest victim was one of our orphanage
girls Pamela what Pam if I didn't have
sister Leslie when my
parents funding the orphanage is the
least I could do your parents what
pearls where are they your evening
attire has already been laid out sir God
Alfred in that hat Immaculate or redhead
James Gordon you've got a dirty mind you
do my money's on blonde
mother Leslie is she based on somebody I
can't think of a Leslie but I'm sure the
the comments will let me know when I'm
wrong but nothing's coming to mind the
elor stuff throws me just enough that I
sometimes miss the obvious that's good
yeah it's nice I could just watch but
then they Ru the day that I didn't catch
a thing it's your job it's your one job
it's your only worth in this
[Music]
life as much as we're joking like I love
the aura of all this yeah it's so pretty
I just love spending time
here and Batman just suits this level of
Gothic yeah now make the Elmer fud movie
there's a Batman versus Elmer fud it's
delightful I need
it this ominous slow walk MH i' be too
controlled for Joker my peace care CR
either that or it's somebody like we
wouldn't think
of oh
oh an
abatar oh sheeps cat like reflexes I was
going to say you can't kill Selena they
did kill poison I in the opening that's
true no I was characters are are you
know highly
[Music]
Expendable
o
sweet oh
yes good sound design yeah
fights ooh it
is yeah you just got
porked oh
the old meat door trapo solution he's
more skilled than I would have thought I
don't need or want your help and before
you gallantly offer to escort me home
let me assure you I am quite capable
of yeah one of the best uses of the
disappearing that was so good this
Ripper is far worse than the lunatic
you're searching for he's a skilled
Hunter you ought to have breakfast with
Hugo Strange up at Arkham Asylum you can
compare useless
theories I prefer
I ran into your Ripper earlier this
evening approximately 6' 3 in 250 lb
left-handed rashal
ghou it's very cabal I mean goes with
some of the conspiracy theories every
woman in Gotham is in danger
commissioner a letter from Jack to the
Gotham Gazette we've convinced them to
refrain from publishing it hide your
kids hide your wife this Uninvited visit
to my home will not be repeated this
house is my refuge set apart from all
the corruption of
go twice in a row man both great
[Music]
excellent the Monarch Theater was where
his parents died
[Music]
oh John's other job go go auditioning
I'm available for chus line he's ready
he can can can too wield a mad umbrella
I'm in love well that's great news
Harvey I'm sure you're wife will be glad
to hear
it this is the 19th century don't be
such a dinosaur polyam is all the rage
now Bruce kids are doing it make
yourselves at home gentlemen I certainly
hope not just come out here naked in
front of the both of
us the shade of purple to mirror her 90s
outfit from the Jeff lobe run of long
Halloween this is my club we can catch a
handsome here I'd invite you in for a
drink drink but men only at least we
still have something as it should be yes
a handsome what's that expression I've
never heard that once we should Lear new
catch a handsome you know we're going to
a men's club you're a fascinating
subject and what have you learned you
were raised in a small Regional circus
probably in a family of performers at
some traumatic event connected to the
scar in your left arm that you try to
conceal LED you to the continent where
you reinvented yourself as a nightclub
performer nothing
else
sister Leslie Tomkins one of the few
people who knew me as a boy she was the
one who told me you were kind she took
me in too she takes in all the helpless
protects them oh I've been a fool Bruce
what fetch me a handsome quickly why did
you say those ideas why did you say
those series of
sentences fetch me a handsome quick I
now know less what it means I
know just like a handsome spirit tool is
it a is it a a Corvette of some kind me
a handsome got to Google it Marlene what
are you doing here a warm cut is waiting
for you and you're out here in the cold
H you've been at the bottle nah it's
Batman this guy's the old woman again is
it marleene
Quinn Marlene quinzel what do you know I
feel like it is a Marlene quinzel so
this is it then I won't beg and I won't
go hysterical I won't give you the
satisfaction know this I forgive you o
wow no I thought he was going to stop
her stop him
seriously
Bruce wow
nice oh I like that it's an attic
instead of caves see up the B the
B it's a membership pin from the Dian
Isis Club it was at the scene the Batman
will return it to Gordon after my
analysis and this does however narrow
the field considerably including the
mayor Harvey even Hugo Strange virtually
every wealthy man in Gotham testing your
fingerprints Theory again there are't
prints just a few fibers in the Fastener
if I could match these it will have to
wait I've laid out your morning clothes
I have my own manner of mourning oh she
wouldn't want you to be alone right now
it's how I work best
Alfred is that like a bowl full of nugs
on his what is that right
there how do you think he funds all this
yeah your original drug dealer that's
right of the Resurrection to eternal
life through our Lord Jesus
Christ it was you may be like unto his
glorious
body amen or maybe it's like a group of
people is it Hugo Strange cuz we haven't
seen him like a Hugo Strange thing I
don't know they keep so obviously evil
yeah well and Harvey was tired and now
bulock was tired like I feel like
they're making a point out of people who
being tired which is a weird Theory this
Ripper is very tired out last night
killing Mr Wayne handwriting is just
laziness oh I read your monograph on the
habits of clinically degenerate lunatics
you believe their cure lies in surgery
oh you knew sister Leslie no I came for
professional reasons to hotamy it's all
the AG he is here you know who he is
pardon me Mr Wayne the commissioner was
wondering if you'll be coming to the
memorial yes Chief I'll be right
there I'm sure you could find a way to
tell the Batman to to come to my office
tonight midnight strange I don't know
who strange too clever for your own good
man
gotta we don't take kindly to IMM
Merchants you think that's so sister
Leslie want you to askit her own funeral
but I'm hungry Jason he is not worth the
trouble get him loose huh are they just
they they're all the Robins yeah Jason
TI tick I occasionally have odd jobs
that need doing oh call upon me here
you'll not go away hungry instead of the
Red Hood he's the
redhaired yeah follow me Mr Bruce Wayne
I recognized you sneaking around the
churchyard uhoh if you think you can do
me like you did sister Lesley you're
dead wrong fella F me in Skinner's head
everybody knows me oh must
your head
damn that went well walls are closing
in
yes
whoa who's got this special head cage
yeah someone messed up man Arkham's
rough wow you go strange with people in
a pit a fual even a bit early Batman
these masks the ones you choose to wear
they show the true self like in that
Twilight Zone episode of course you
understand why I couldn't say more
at we saw those wrists we both know you
cannot do your work on me I'm not a
street walker it's antithetical to your
neosis you
can't dang dude this is a tough one for
Batman yeah P getting killed around
[Music]
him
I want to study this suit too did he
throw him in the pit he let other people
kill him is he going to use him as some
kind of
example oh
god wow
wow
no like do any of them look like
anybody that mask I wonder if they're
going to do some kind of like cord ofy
thing with the dianis club oh
interesting I don't know I mean he just
got the mask but at the same time I
wonder if there are multiple
Jacks
[Music]
oh who Batman
moment
W
waa
steampunk
cool he nice
chemistry oh yep Police Headquarters the
Batman has murdered doctor strange and
escaped in the police Airship oh
different
one yes whoa whoa
dang very good at the
knife yeah I'm like what other villains
fight with blades I'm thinking Raj with
the he's got a a scabber blade a
lot nice yeah of the Silhouettes cloak
in a
cape
wow this would be very cool in live
action
[Music]
yeah yes fisty cuffs on a blimp blimps
to
cuffs oh oh boy oh
boy
God right into the blades Indiana Jones
them someone's going to get
it Indiana Jones in him
yeah jeez
dude
dang
what are you leaping to boy we got him
down to the
Nubs whoa crash like a lead
Zeppelin oh nice wow ouch
ow on
fire
Dam Batman him there he
is oh
[Music]
no oh
nope he's definitely such just a guy in
this yeah and what about the too many
just killed at Arkham we don't know what
happened for certain Bulldog we catch
him and if he's guilty he hangs but I
want him alive
je just want to study this suit it looks
like he's got like a double breasted
like bomber jacket yeah he's got like a
cloak and then something underneath and
then the pouches are huge
get in there you go do your downtown
escapades usually end with excessive
bleeding the belt and gloves must go
immediately any of the bat
autal hold I say open up open up in the
name of the lord they're making it
they're doing it yeah oh is there a
problem
officer no Mr Wayne we've just
been you should head home dangerous
characters on the streets tonight
anything else
gentlemen you must commit completely to
the role let's finish the
scene repetition you must practice yes
practice practice yes yes yes the Bad
and the cat ah this even got my lowkey
romance great The Cat In The Gaslight
loving it the boys just found her show
me ah Marley Quinn I saw the circus in
the acrobatic Dismount you used in your
show and then of course in your fighting
style in the whip lion tamer just like
he's saying about I grew up with those
cats they don't have anyone else to
protect them until the Batman does he
have a story oh you better believe it oh
your parents are you making them pay the
criminals they could never pay enough
could they
a no cute Bruce Wayne you are under
arrest for the murder of one Marlene
Mahoney who think hard Wayne maybe
you'll remember I'll contact Harvey
he'll clear this all up he's the one who
suggested we look for Mr Wayne in your
hotel
excellent you can't imagine I'm actually
the Ripper o get him out of my sight
jeez as the nature of these crimes is so
detestable and Mr Wayne has ample
Financial Resources to escape justice
justice BFF will remove the prisoner to
Blackgate Prison at two Harvey you
really are a two-faced man yeah you're
just chumming we we we went got a
handsome together you know what he is
duplicitous oh he truly man of Duality
he is dichotomy all of it
he just wanted to know what a handsome
was too was the problem nobody told
please enjoy your stay at the hotel
Blackgate yeah we're looking forward to
seeing you check
out in a body B prison jokes you think
one of your friends is framing you one
of my mentors says that when you
eliminate the impossible whatever
remains however improbable must be the
truth o unfortunately my nocturnal
habits ude me from providing an adequate
account of my whereabouts well you'll
just have to explain to Gordon that
you're the
Batman Batman has an ironclad Alibi for
the first murder Batman's Effectiveness
depends upon every moment you're in here
puts women in danger if you won't tell
Gordon then I will yes step up bro I'll
be damned if I'll let another girl be
murdered so you can keep your precious
secret but I think ultimately you'll
find this was all for the best love
everyone's motivation yeah that's a
solid ultimatum bring this to my
townhouse on Bell Avenue and my man
there will give you $100 get it there
within 30 minutes he'll give you $200
get it there and 10 I'll give you half a
clown I need a free
pizza
excellent who is next who will face
Cyrus Gold oh Cyrus gold no weaklings
I'll be you in private no time like the
present yeah
[Music]
buddy
nice
nice great touch with the
stick why you sitting on your asses it's
a damn D Brook
there Irish Batman oh that's so good
blury man I hope that was Bruce
Greenwood just doing his best bro that
was fantastic I was gon to say where
where what uh you know lineage does the
Wayne Sur name come from it's got to be
some Irish I need to see Commissioner
Gordon immediately you never slow down
do you I can't imagine what I ever saw
an like
you sounds awful awful rippery someone
is liable to get hurt and sooner or
later you
will real rippery he's down at the
fairgrounds making sure everything ship
shap the fairgrounds hurry the Riddler's
going to flood the fair inel Ripper the
Ridler yep that's who it is yep if you
bet on every horse you're going to win
something one one of those it's gonna be
no one it's going to be Jack the Ripper
yeah I still say we take the wagon the
horse and whatever this is and SK ble
we're going to do the job Jason now shut
your bone box and push it's them three
in a trench coat their Jack yeah solved
it Coy in your
face good job now go
yes what do we got what's the tech
[Music]
yeah I love this too this feels like
very appropriately vatman but perfectly
out of History where Fair blending those
worlds together yeah
yeah Ace
hey I thought I was all alone
embarrassing as it sounds you gave me
quite a start a I like them two working
together
Selena
oh false
wall don't don't tell me is it Gordon it
can't be Gordon I need to talk to your
husband is he home he's a good man what
the best man in this horrible City what
did a woman come here looking for him
walk in here off the streets I should
hope
not no uh-uh I don't believe
this no
oh this this could just be his ch ear
day
wall oh look at them gloves oh no no no
we liked him so much damn damn I never
would have predicted it no they totally
got me that's not bad actually we named
everyone else that's not bad I I should
have called the second Harvey started to
be real suspicious there at the end I
was like yeah kid
mislead he needs to be severe
no he's gentle as a lamb with us he
simply burns the sin out of us
whoa that is
nutty I suppose it's a dreadful betrayal
of confidence but I simply see no other
way it's in your very nature to play
false with your illicit
lover
uh damn oh
[Music]
no yes
that's a cosplay waiting to happen
yeah no a 7% solution of Lum 3% heroin
and alcohol woo but it is hardly a cure
forry only I only Jack has the remedy
for that vile ill
wow damn Nation you'll pay for that oh
was that a word at this time Jim just
invented it he did he's a sophisticated
guy Jim Jack
Gordon tag the no okay
fine dra
cat
oh back bike Sweet It's like got
Tomahawk that thing is awesome yeah it's
like made out of a piece of a train
engine or something the oversweet
fragrance you use to cover your
putrifying stench nearly burns my
eyes oh we have a b
sign amazing oh that's so good
niceoo I love it yes very good touch oh
my God and it's fighting James and oh so
good and perfect like smudgy like
yeah no nice try what does a light in
the darkness do it draws flies vile like
you can't have no light man I promise
the people of Gotham to clean the scum
thieves murderers confidence Men
immigrants illiterates anarchists it's a
big old list not a great guy your
corruption and Decay will spill down
over this Carnival as a warning to all
your kind am man is a real incel here
dark yes sir get him Batman
left-handed oh the nuns beat that
wickedness out of me use my right except
for Jack's
work dang that's a cool twist too my
sister was ruler slapped by a nun for
right and Lefty really yep damn have you
any other injuries no I'm Bruce
jeez
dude oh they do really make him feel
like a prize fighter or an ex fighter
oh I'm a trained fighter London prize
ring rules there were no rules at antium
though were there James there are no
rules in hell yeah that's a
bar o
it's a cool set piece too with the gas
light becoming part of the yeah
destruction set
piece come on Selena
ah Into The
Inferno man what a set piece
yeah uhoh don't save him I know you got
to
me oh God but he's going to pull you
over oh
no oh nah man you're stuck in here with
me sweet
choice whoa I saw your work on your wife
they're the worst problems of all sell
themselves too cheap what an impossible
to please Ian
guy
who this is where we belong no it's
where you
belong I paid Houdini $300 for that
trick yes you did amazing Houdini
canonical unofficial sidekick you know
helping out y razell ghoul in this
universe Houdini that's going to be my
Batman comic is the Adventures of Batman
Houdini oh wow is he what a shot
whoa
no cleansing
fire
wow
damn it's couldn't happen to a nicer guy
yep
what a trustful
yeah it's good thing that steel was soft
never mind until it
wasn't let's go bat and the
cat
whoa just feel the heat
yeah you should have run when you had
the chance well I was fairly doped
up
my man and the robins yes where there
smoke there's fire and there you'll
always be
sir Alfred always clutch no wonder
Alfred's a constant he's always a great
character no matter how big how small
and I love that the robins are in this
yeah Belong To You Alfred good Lord no
sir they belong to
you sweet pick up Sister Leslie's work
take on some Wards in a time we're
having Wards actually might be less
problematic oh God and the hope of
Gotham withed it was all phony anyway oh
we'll make something new something
better that's right I like these kids
we'll keep them little bat family
starting
out cool nicely done yep Bruce Greenwood
and Jennifer
Carpenter Chris CIO a lot of voice
actors oh Tera strong was Marley that's
why I was like Harley yeah I was like
it's at least got to be a vocal tribute
of some
kind dang man that was intense that was
very cool that was intense yeah man
absolutely I mean obviously like the
aesthetic choice to yeah set it in this
what is that the 19 the 1800s the 19th
century 19th century yeah no I just love
the atmosphere and I I really enjoyed
the air that they cuz I I I saw the run
time I was like oh an hour and 17
minutes that's on the shorter side but
uh yeah I thought this managed to like
breathe very nicely while also feeling
like I don't know it had that like dark
but fun aura that like an elor's Tale To
Me often does and it didn't like hold on
too long to anything because it was an
elor so the stakes were the right amount
of high like you you got to breathe it
in have the fun novelty of Who's Who and
then like it dove into the story and it
didn't overstay its welcome in the else
World which I liked yeah and it plays
off of the associ
or you go strange you're like oh he's
got to be up he's just another kind of
around involved but not truly really
significantly responsible or anything
like that and and the implication he did
know who Bruce Wayne was was fun because
that's one of the things you go strange
does in the comics uh like the the
playing our expectation of who it's
going to be against like I really
thought it was going to be rash hugle
like I because I was like the way he
fought the way like all those things was
really fun as a comic fan to have the S
World Absol absolutely yeah yeah even
the mutton shops rashal go looks like he
fits the 19th century totally I mean
that's the thing is I see something like
this and I'm like man I would watch I
would watch a series set in this
universe you know I would watch those
takes on like so many the potential for
so many fun takes and adaptations of
characters just you know clearly
presents itself through something like
this and I really like the ones that we
got like I really liked the little IV
inclusion uh you know Selena Kyle I
thought was really nicely handled here
um but also too I mean for how you know
compact it is in a lot of ways it's not
I like that they also didn't go too far
and like over stuff it with like that's
a guy that's single you're not like yeah
so like it it's allowed to be its own
thing while also having you know a lot
of the things that you want from this
Pro and the first Tim Drake sure finally
we I mean the robin allowed for Tim
Drake he's a robin too uh but it allowed
for us to discover new things like that
which I thought was exciting and and I
don't know this was like really unique
for an elor because I felt the stakes
were high enough that I cared about
everybody but it didn't feel oh it is
Mike MCN NOA hell yeah 1989 that was the
comic and he and he wrote like Hellboy
Comics yeah Mike mca's iconic his art is
so specifically him and yeah Hellboy his
big claim to fame as father Callahan
yeah Gordon oh okay fights Gordon into a
ferris wheel where Gordon yeah okay but
where's Gordon's commission uh oh there
he is he was credited way lower got
Scott Patterson I saw the Callahan I was
like oh it's father Callahan I don't
remember him um must been a small part
John Demario was
bulock uh yui was Harvey which is
awesome yeah yeah yeah uh I love Bruce
Tim got a cameos Arkham radio man he's
had a couple I feel like we've seen a
couple of these where he's cameoed his
like little bit parts and stuff like
that I like that a lot yeah um but and
two I I mean again oh no no no that was
Barbara Gordon right that was Barbara
Gordon with the the that's that's that's
the thing is is there are enough
characters that you're like okay wait a
minute cuz yeah it's like you there's
like does Harvey always come with a
Gilda I feel like that I associate that
character so strongly with the long
Halloween that like she's mentioned here
and I'm like I usually think of her as
just a long Halloween charact like I
don't think I mean Harvey D pops in and
out but he's been toofaced for so long I
don't think back to the Harvey days uh
also I love that Anthony had was Alfred
because he's so good on Ted lasso is
that who that was Ted lasso zone of
course yes for owner dude
Giles freaking him I forget his name
yeah what's his name uh what is his name
he's the former owner of the football
club the enemy the antagonist he's uh uh
uh there he is Hannah watting Ham's
douchy ex-husband yes we need TV there
we go TV TV what's his name what's his
name oh yeah Ted rert there you go yeah
that evil bugger and the Repo Man if any
Genetic Opera heads are out there um he
was so good as Alfred uh yeah and I like
I love never would have thought of that
but I love that choice and even if we
never got to see it live action I'm like
a cool I'm glad he's in the pantheon he
played frankenfurter on the Picadilly
stage for Rocky Horror oh that's excit
love this man more and more the more
credits I read had doing the work he
records albums he's uh he he does
musical stuff too good man but uh yeah
no I thought that was actually a really
cool wrap up to this to have it be
Gordon a because I I wouldn't have
expected it Gordon is always a character
and especially through the character
characterization they had here uh I
thought that he was you know very he had
all his Gordon flavors that you want
where you feel comforted by his presence
you you like him generally he seems like
a guy with Integrity but I thought the
reasoning they found to make it him as
it pertains to this world uh was well
thought out and it would have to be
somebody who again they go back to that
thing of like he's a sophisticated guy
who's making himself look you know like
an uneducated guy and it's a good having
the letter in his own pocket saying that
that they going to see it him dreaming
of Barbara Gordon being hurt as a
mislead because he's just having the
nightmare about his own wife being
horrible yes absolutely and like the way
that it bounces off of the whole Batman
thing is like you know he's got the
Playboy public persona but he's out here
you know in the nighttime obviously you
know enacting justice so then you have
like the reverse the guy who in you know
plain day is upstanding and is enacting
that Justice and at night is you know
bringing to life the most perverse the
most sort of crazed and zealous version
of that yeah real aab situation
sure yeah and I mean too it's got that
Gruff kind of nasty like yeah all the
coppers feel like they just bludgeon you
at any point and like i' love that the
only one we usually only have one cop we
can trust in Gotham and that's Gordon
because he trusts Batman and in this
case it's a very clever twist because I
never saw it coming I also really like
the use of the iconography of Gordon
like I love that they use the bat light
against him instead of he's the one
using it like there were just so many
moments that are iconic Batman moments
used really creatively here yeah no
totally like I I I feel like this this
was very gratifying in that way because
again it had so many satisfying things
that you would want and so many things
that made me feel like I was in some
ways watching like a classic episode in
a good way not you know sometimes
calling something like an episode is is
like a slight but I thought but yeah
this this made me feel like I was
watching the animated series at certain
points again and I love the little Sly
asides and you having uh the three
robins paid tribute to having Alfred
kind of bring them on of his own accord
and we're on the Wiki page right now
just to get the cast but I see here it
says uh referencing Sherlock Holmes they
made the Baker Street of regulars into
Robins that is so fun hey yeah well and
that's the thing too is yeah you've got
Sherlock Holmes in here you obviously
have stuff that hearkens to from hell
and I think having Jack the Ripper is a
really good historical pull for a Batman
story like this it's it's got so much
Mystique already such a larger than life
figure you know much has been much ink
has been spilled over the blood he has
spilled I mean alen Mo stuff for Comic
fans like you said that run frame like
there's definitely moments where it even
ties into our mythology in comics yeah
totally so like this and and the way it
inhabited that world used the historical
fiction but also used the again Batman
characters to tie it all around I was
like damn if these weren't all you know
clearly fictional characters I'd be like
this is kind of a solid Theory right
here yeah like oh you don't I wonder if
there was any theories that the Ripper
was a cop I bet there must be there has
to you know I mean like I feel like
there was a foundation there in
something cuz you know it's like yeah
you have that whole thing about like
he's got a a knowledge of like s he like
all of his murders are very surgical
yeah and they have at least a moment
here where you see like okay Gordon's at
least been trained in autopsy and they
say like oh these are sort of similar to
autopsies in a way and uh and yeah it's
like I have to imagine that in the real
case like I I'm not an expert by any
stretch but I feel like they've they've
looked at surgeons or people with that
kind of experience but they would have
had to have looked uh at you know some
kind of law enforcement or coroner
somebody like that I'm also really
curious like what the I just wrote
scrolled on C response people seem to
like this quite a bit but I'm very
curious about how something that turns a
beloved character this evil went because
like I think it was very useful but I
know a lot of people like I can't trange
something that like no it's like an else
world like that's the fun of it like
Thomas Wayne being Batman changes
everything like the Joker
like that's what I like about an not
when it's one little twe when they go
Full Tilt like this I got to be fully
surprised yeah totally and it's like he
fought in the War it's you know's he's
traumatized from like the Civil War yeah
uh so like yeah it's it's a great again
it makes sense that if he had been put
into that moment in time these events
come together where they not have if he
is yeah of a later period in time like
we're used to seeing him and this very
success F did a thing another of the
animated movies we watched a while ago I
think failed at one of the only villains
I didn't like in the Teen Titans where I
was like he's just an angry Zealot and
it didn't feel weighted blood I hated
this guy yeah like all of his zealotry
was like gross like the performance the
writing everything felt like I wanted
him to feel like yeah you just feel like
the like the the anger and the like
righteous hatred it's it's yeah it's
that he feels righteous in that
awfulness and I didn't feel that from
Brother Blood yeah it's that looking
down you're looking down on everyone as
just filthy and and agents of you know
Idle Hands of the devil agents of you
know corrosion and all that stuff and
and everybody he looks upon comes with
this sort of scourge of judgment and uh
and yeah like I thought they captured
that psychosis really nicely and two you
know we don't really see him go to
Arkham or whatever but it's like it's in
fitting with the kinds of people would
wind up there but also in a very again
historically appropriate way because you
would have had you know the the very
moralistic arguments and the class-based
arguments and stuff like that and which
I like how they addressed and it didn't
get heavy-handed but they were like put
at the top and then it stayed part of
the like the fabric yeah and it makes
sense too because there are like you
know it comes in varying degrees because
they touch on again the class angle and
the idea that like oh you know if they
were killing men you would have figured
this out a long time ago or at least and
then people counter well you know if it
was affluent women at the very least we
would have figured this out a long time
ago it's you know it's uh the the women
on the fringes of society who are being
plagued upon and how people look on that
I feel like that's you know a a Nuance
that's very reasonable I feel like
anytime you directly be like he's
targeting women because of this reason
you know it dog whistles certain people
to be
like but this makes perfect sense and it
also again lines up with the mo of
historical Jack the Ripper so yeah
having I thought having that really
strong Selena perspective as she was a
favorite I really love that her motiv
was justified I love that she would have
done exactly what she did at every turn
I loved her origin I thought the cat
element was fun fun fact Greg Griffin is
the voice of sister Leslie Tomkins and
Jason Todd and also Selena Kyle's
singing voice what a range of different
roles in one movie that's singing voice
and I love that we got a musical number
yeah full on which told plot elements
yeah and a and a and a romantic subplot
again that felt earned felt earned it
felt uh natural and organic and it
fueled the plot it gave him an alibi it
also gave him an out it also gave her a
lot to do like that's what you want a
true love story to feel like and she
also was like an Irene uh what's her
name uh Sherlock oh oh oh oh yeah
ohler is it Adler yes it is she got to
be like that stand in which also is a
really fun female lead of the time and
dressed like her but also nodded towards
Selena Kyle's Tim sale outfit which is
that purple that might have been a
coincidence but it felt like that tra of
purple so a lot of fun yeah and with the
the the Sherlock Holmes I mean then you
have Alfred is kind of like John Watson
the true John Watson not the bumbly guy
but yeah the guy who's looking out for
the wellbeing of Sherlock Holmes and
facilitating you know his Brilliance
along the way this was fun man I really
dug this yeah this this was terrific and
it makes me curious to go and read the
comic and and see what that take I'm so
glad I haven't read it in so long
because I don't I think the Gordon twist
is accurate but I don't remember yeah
but I think that came out in ' 89 and I
think I probably read it in like '96
like I remember I think I was like a
child that had just discovered Hellboy
so I was like oh
so it would not be something I remember
at all but uh that was a blast yeah this
was terrific I really like this a lot
and again like such economical but also
fluid breathable storytelling and yeah
like really great use of everything at
this movie's disposal thank you elor
that was so much fun do we have uh any
patrons oh we're gonna save that for the
next Super all right all right we're
going to be saving that so super sexy
rejects pay pay attention stay tuned one
of those things pay tuned to our
adventures with and of and about
Superman very excited to dive into more
of that uh and please let us know in the
comments what is your favorite elor let
us know if there's any of the other else
worlds you want us to check out do you
want to to go back to tomorrow first
what do you want next hit that
notification Bell hit that like button
leave comments below and we'll be back
some more goodness very very soon and
let us know what you thought of this one
because I'm really curious with this
more than most uh how this was received
because obviously we weren't we weren't
there for it so much love reject Nation
we'll see you very soon with another
adventure in see
t